- It's something that I
don't usually talk about
because I'm afraid that I'm
making people uncomfortable.
It's something that affects me
in almost every aspect of life.
(gentle pleasant music)
(whooshing)
(hinges creak)
- There's something about having
dark skin on a woman's body
that shapes the way she
moves through the world.
There's something about having
darker skin on a male body
that shapes the way in which
he moves through the world.
It has real life stakes.
- From what I've seen growing up,
dark skin equates to being poor,
- dirty,
- rat shit,
- they tend to be the bad
guys in Tyler Perry movies,
- straight from the border,
- that doesn't even make any sense.
I'm not deemed as beautiful,
therefore I am not beautiful,
and those two are not
really mutually exclusive.
- Could it be that something
as early as colonization
or slavery is primarily responsible
for our beauty standards today?
We're talking about who works in the field
and who works in the house.
We're also talking about rape,
the rape of slaves to produce
people who were known as
mulattoes, or mixed race.
These standards of beauty travel.
Eurocentric standards of beauty travel.
- In the Dominican
society and our culture,
they have a phrase that's like,
(speaks in foreign language)
advancing the Dominican population
and making sure we're going
into how they say the better.
If you're lighter,
you're bettering the race
and you're bettering the island,
versus if you're just being you.
- I would get called the blackness.
One joke that really
stuck with me was like,
oh, Edgar's so black that
when he leaves a car,
the check engine light turns on.
That was a reference to my
skin being as dark as oil.
I felt ugly being of a darker skin tone,
so I tried to gel my hair,
or I started listening
to skater punk music.
So I tried, culturally, to lighten myself,
if that makes sense.
- I went on a trip to Korea with my mom.
Some woman walked up to
my mom, and she asked,
"Why is your daughter so dark?"
In Korea, you have to be pale,
and I almost felt like a foreigner
and not so much Korean anymore.
- When we turn off the lights, they say,
"Oh, Selorm, where did you go?"
Or, "Oh, you're really pretty
for a dark-skinned girl."
Are you saying that my
race and just the fact
that I am black, is that
not attractive in general?
- I remember one time that I wanted to be
an angel in a parade.
At that time, they were like
kind of racist, you know.
They didn't like black
people to be angels,
and my mommy got kind of freak out.
She was going like, "Please don't,
"you cannot be an angel because
they gonna laugh at you."
I said, "But mommy, I am an angel."
And finally, I was an angel.
And I was the only black
angel walking in the street.
And my mommy was so proud
about it, and I was proud too.
- My mom started buying me a
cream called Fair & Lovely.
I was in third grade when I started using
(laughs) bleaching creams.
And the whole general idea was,
if I'm lighter, I'll have a better life.
I'll find somebody that's
gonna love me. (laughs)
There'd still be light and dark patches
on my body and my face. (sighs)
It was painful, it would hurt,
and I started breaking out in bad rashes,
and no one said anything.
I had to stop it myself.
- How do we fix this?
We think critically about colorism.
We think about where it began,
and where it begins and ends with us.
- I think change starts with
providing more diversity.
You know, providing more examples
of people that look like you.
- If you look at telenovelas,
they usually cast
the dark-skinned person as the villain,
and if you never met a Latino before,
you're gonna somewhat think that.
- So in Japanese media,
I honestly don't think
I've ever seen a darker-skinned female.
I think it would be nice to see a change.
- It needs to start
within our own culture,
where we can't have Will Smith
filling in every slot for black people.
Giving dark-skinned people roles
that are not only supporting
roles but leading roles.
- I mean a legit, badass,
007 Latino James Bond,
that'd be pretty dope, I'm just sayin'.
- If I could give a
message to someone like me,
- who's kind of looking at
himself and feeling insecure,
- just know, baby, you beautiful.
- Believe in yourself.
- Just be you.
- You are perfect just the way you are.
That's something that
no one has ever told me.
- And your skin color is a gift.
It's never been a blemish or a problem.
- When you grow up and
you look in the mirror,
and you're proud of who you
are, it will make sense,
and all the other voices will go away.
And all that's gonna be left is you.
(gentle pleasant music)
(whooshing)
(hinges creak)